[Música]
sri lanka está de celebración este
sábado marcó el 75 aniversario de su
independencia de Reino Unido con un
desfile militar y promesas de un futuro
mejor del presidente
eh oc shaktimate
Ya se han formulado las bases y los
cimientos de una nueva economía fuerte
estamos completando con éxito la difícil
etapa necesaria para obtener el apoyo
del fmi esperamos tener su
consentimiento sin demora
Emiliano pero justo la situación
económica fue lo que opaco la
celebración con un gran descontento
entre los ciudadanos que salieron a
protestar especialmente desde el
movimiento estudiantil y el clero
religioso para muchos no hay nada que
celebrar vullura en estos momentos la
gente se enfrenta a una multitud de
problemas no pueden comer tres veces al
día hay una gran represión la gente no
tiene derecho a expresar sus opiniones
sin ninguna vergüenza gasta millones de
rupias en celebraciones del día de la
independencia la gente dice que gastemos
ese dinero para aliviar al pueblo
Y es que la isla de 22 millones de
habitantes está sumida en la peor crisis
económica desde su independencia de
Reino Unido en 1948 entre los
principales problemas la fuerte
inflación el desplome de la rupia y la
escasez de productos de primera
necesidad como medicinas o combustibles
algo que hizo que el expresidente gota
vaya a raya paxa huyera del país y
dimitiera del cargo luego de que las
manifestaciones llegaran a su propia
casa y la situación no es mucho mejor
ahora por eso el nuevo gobierno ha
pedido un rescate de 2.900 a millones de
dólares al fmi y se están implementando
reformas a para reactivar la economía